JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Julia.
I'm ready and willing
and able to talk to you
about this concept of blurring
the infrastructure platform
divide.
It's something I'm
really excited about.
We've been talking
about it for a while,
because it seems like
there's this really
big split in between the two.
Who here works with
infrastructure as a service?
A few people.
How about platform as a service?
And it tends-- it's
an interesting choice
that people think that
they have to make.
So let's dive in.
So right now, if
you're trying to build
a cloud-powered application--
whether you're building it
from scratch, or you're maybe
trying to move something
onto the cloud-- you feel like
you have to make this choice.
And it's like
almost a reckoning.
You have to decide.
Put your money where your mouth.
Say, OK, well, I'm going
to go with infrastructure.
And for us on Google
Cloud Platform,
that's our Compute
Engine, right?
And it's a choice that a
lot of people tend to make.
It's a familiar concept.
You can develop against a Linux
operating system that you know,
that's familiar to you.
It's an easy sell to developers,
because they're already
familiar working in
that environment.
It's an easy sell to the people
that hold the purse strings,
because they understand
it really well.
They've had to buy servers.
They've had to make
that investment.
This is just in a slightly
different form factor.
But there's a lot of the hidden
costs in terms of overhead.
You have to manage
the operating system.
You have to manage the updates.
I'm seeing some nods
in the audience,
and some like, oh, yeah.
That's an investment.
That's a lot to make.
And so the amount of code--
the infrastructure code--
that you have to write
dramatically expands.
You have to hire Ops
people, or DevOps folks.
People who fill the
function of DevOps.
And you have to put
a lot of investment
into maintaining your
various environments, right?
Sometimes they're not the same.
But you get a lot
of flexibility.
Anything you could apt-get
install on your local machine
is probably going
to be generally OK.
On your virtual machine.
But let's say you don't want
to make that investment.
You don't want to
necessarily develop
all of that surrounding code
that really doesn't contribute
to your core features.
Your offering-- the
product that you're
trying to build-- probably
may not have something
to do with the intricacies of
how the network is configured.
So you go with the platform
as a service approach.
This idea that you've
got these managed
runtimes that take care of a
lot of the common scenarios.
And for us, that's
Google App Engine.
And Google App
Engine provides a ton
of different APIs that make
common tasks really easy.
And it's a great way to go if
you want to develop rapidly.
Maybe you're a startup up.
You want to get your minimum
viable product out the door.
It's a great way
to go, because you
don't have to worry about the
infrastructure surrounding it.
You let Google
handle that for you.
Let the platform as a service
provider handle it for you.
So that's kind of
what's generally
seen as the trade-off.
But what if you didn't want
to make that trade-off?
As we all say when
we're trying to think
of new products or new features,
there's got to be a better way.
And we think there is.
So what if this wasn't
a choice that you
had to make at the outset?
And you saw this slide
just a few minutes ago.
We crib notes from each
other all the time.
So we think that the dichotomy
between infrastructure
as a service and
platform as a service
is actually a false dichotomy.
We don't think it's real.
We think that's the state
of how things have been,
but it doesn't have
to be that way.
And so that's our next
generation of cloud.
Give you the flexibility
of infrastructure,
but give you the ability to
be agile in your development
with managed services.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about some
of the features that
allow you to bridge
the gap between platform
and infrastructure.
And we're really
excited about it.
I'm really excited
about it myself.
So let's start taking a look
at managed virtual machines.
So I'm going to make my bad
pun here, so prepare yourself.
At their core-- pun
definitely intended--
they're based on Compute
Engine virtual machines.
I'll be the one laughing at it.
It's all good.
So what you get is
the same strengths
that Compute Engine has.
The variety of machine types.
The access to the
native resources.
And the fact that it's simply a
virtual machine, except better.
It has the same
strengths of App Engine,
some of the same
strength of App Engine,
like easy access to the managed
services that we provide there,
and the developer productivity.
The ability to develop quickly.
How many of you have
heard the phrase,
you get Google as your
site reliability engineer?
Ooh.
I get to introduce
something new.
Yay!
OK.
So this is the idea that
with Google Managed Services,
you should be able
to get something
that's kind of meteorite-proof.
It's kind of one of
those ridiculous things--
I'm hearing laughter-- those
ridiculous things that we say.
Because with Google
services, you
can rest assured that
if, for some reason,
a meteorite hits one
of our data centers,
we're going to be
on call fixing it.
We're going to be moving.
We're going to be
managing the disaster.
figuring out how
to keep the services running.
And we do that.
And we have site reliability
engineers who do this for us.
And so you don't have to handle
the pager anymore, right?
Who here has been-- I
guess now it's a cellphone.
Maybe text.
I'm not sure.
Who here's been woken
up by the pager,
by the cellphone, when
your site goes down?
We've got a few.
We know how this goes.
It makes us cry inside.
But the idea with Google as
your site reliability engineer
is that you can sleep.
You can sleep through.
Google is going to keep
everything running.
It's going to be awesome.
So if we take a look at
the graphic on the right
here, with virtual
machines, it's really
operates in between--
managed virtual machines--
it operates in between
infrastructure and platform.
With App Engine you can
say, oh, you know what?
I have an app on App Engine.
But all of a sudden I need to do
something that I traditionally
couldn't do with a platform.
Maybe it's access
to a library that's
not allowed on the platform.
Maybe it's some intense
data analysis in R.
Or access to graphic
processing libraries in C.
That you typically couldn't do
with the platform as a service
approach.
You can spin up a
managed virtual machine
from App Engine, have
it take care of it,
and all a sudden you've broken
out of platform as a service.
Gotten the flexibility
of infrastructure.
But it's not just
the other services
that managed virtual
machines have access to.
Because these
things are managed,
we can do things like
co-locate your virtual machines
near each other.
So they have fast communication.
So, again, you don't
have to worry about it.
The second that we'll
talk about is this concept
of replica pools that
you heard introduce
just a little bit earlier.
And this is the
idea that you give
as a base template for what you
want your machine to look like.
And we'll take that
template composed
of the image, the metadata,
what you want going on
in that virtual
machine, and make it so.
So that's one template going
and spinning up many machines
through this replica pool.
And we also do things like
health-checking these instances
to make sure that
they're responding.
And we'll restart
them, so you don't
have to, if something goes awry.
If one of them stops
responding, you don't get paged.
You don't get texted.
We automatically restart them.
And then, finally, because we
love developer productivity,
your developer productivity
is our developer productivity.
And so we've exposed
these features
through the Deployment Manager.
And this is within our
Google Cloud SDK, G Cloud.
And the Deployment
Manager is basically
a JSON-based template--
somewhat like you see here--
that specify a set of
modules for deployment.
And what it does is
it takes that template
and builds a deployment
to that spec.
So you can configure
and specify what
you want you're managed
VMs to look like.
You can specify the disks, the
network, the load balancer.
You can configure how you
want it to load balance.
You can configure auto-scaling
with Deployment Manager.
And it's a really
simple way to create
complex fleets of
virtual machines
that can go out and
do your bidding.
Like a minion.
You'll hear that
word a couple times
throughout the entire day.
I promise.
And within this-- we don't
have it on the slide--
but you can configure
a health model.
Define what you
think is unhealthy
for a virtual machine.
And once it fails
that check, we'll
go and restart that virtual
machine, if, again, something
goes wrong.
So it's pretty cool.
We're going to go back
to a couple of the slides
that you saw in the keynote,
and go into a bit more depth.
Let's look at computing
as a spectrum.
I like to refer to it as
the continuum of computing,
but that's because I
like alliteration, so.
And so at the base we've
got Compute Engine.
Those virtual machines.
Those world-class
optimized virtual machines
that we've done a
lot of work to make
sure they're fast to start up.
Seconds from command to
create to ready to go.
Have fast, reliable
disk performance.
And great networking.
We've done a lot of
work to make sure
that that's a good place
for you to develop.
So if you want to go the
pure infrastructure route,
you can do that.
And you can configure the
networking and the disks,
and manage it with your own code
or with open-source technology
like Chef and Puppet.
And that's a great way to go.
But if you say, you know what?
I don't really want
to manage all of it.
It's a lot of work.
I have better things
or other things
that my developers can be doing.
You can take a step
back and say, OK, well,
let's ask Google to actually
manage our deployments for us.
And you can do that
with Replica Pool.
And then, you can still handle
the operating system updates
and security patches,
but you could
make it a little bit
easier on yourself.
The amount of code to deal with
the infrastructure lessens.
And you can concentrate
more on the code
you write to develop features.
But take a step back, and you
want to hand a little bit more
off.
Focus a little bit more.
Maybe you have a smaller team.
This is great use for when
you have a smaller team,
so you can focus their efforts.
You can move up the stack to
managed virtual machines, which
we went into.
OK.
But you're just
starting out, maybe.
You say, I just want
to write features.
I'm going to write the
stuff that my user is going
to see and play with
on a daily basis.
You can do that with
App Engine today.
You can do it with
managed runtimes.
And we'll manage your
serving stack for you.
But we talked about going up in
the level of abstraction here.
You can get where you want
with agility and flexibility.
Figure out where you
lie in that spectrum.
But what happens if, say, you're
developing your App Engine
application, and you want
to move down the stack.
You can do that.
You can so-called break the
glass beneath your feet,
and get a little bit
more into the details.
And you can do that all the
way down into Compute Engine.
So you can grow your business.
And when you want a
little bit more control,
you can take that back.
It's a really nifty
way to develop.
So let's do a demo.
Yeah.
So we're going to do a demo
of managed virtual machines.
We wanted something to
really illustrate the power
and how awesome it is.
So we thought about what
will be most applicable here.
And we wanted it to be
something that people
dealt with it a lot.
And so this is a
problem-- we're going
to solve a problem
that I've seen people
deal with at the office, over
the lunch table, on planes.
I even gave a tutorial on
my living room couch once.
No joke.
Have I set it up enough?
Yeah.
OK.
We're going to
talk about Sudoku.
So Sudoku is basically a logic
puzzle where you've got a 9
by 9 grid, and you've got
the numbers one through nine,
and they can only appear once in
row, column, and 3 by 3 square.
The ones that are a little
bit darker shaded there.
So I want to win
friends and influence
people with my
mad Sudoku skills.
So I want to make
this automated.
I want something
to solve it for me.
I've got good
skills, but they're
like-- sometimes the
expert puzzles mystify me.
So let's make it happen with
managed virtual machines.
Well, luckily, we've
got Peter Norvig.
Peter Norvig is
one of the parents
of modern artificial
intelligence.
He quite literally
wrote the book
on artificial intelligence.
And I actually
have it back home.
Every 800 pages
was scintillating.
And he wrote a fantastic essay--
I highly recommend you check it
out afterwards-- on
solving any Sudoku puzzle.
If it's solvable, it can do it.
So we can transform a Sudoku
board into a data structure,
feed it into the
algorithm, and it'll
go and give us the answer.
Pretty nifty.
But I've got this.
I've got the one in
the airline magazine.
I've got the one in the booklet
that my parents gave me.
And they're not
going to wait for me
to go move it to a data
structure, run the algorithm,
and then give them the answer.
That's not going to be quite
as impressive as it could
So what we want is to be
able to solve this one.
This one on paper.
And, luckily, there's
computer vision
to help us along the way.
There is a library-- an open
source library-- called OpenCV
that implements a variety of
computer vision libraries.
But my front end for my
application is on App Engine.
And App Engine has
a lot of runtimes,
but it doesn't do C and C+
code, which is what OpenCV is
implemented in.
So I'm in this bit
of a quandary here.
Except I just gave this talk
about managed virtual machines.
We can break the glass of App
Engine, and go to managed VMs.
So this is what our architecture
somewhat looks like.
As far as architecture diagrams
go, it's pretty simple.
Requests for the images come
into the App Engine front end.
We'll feed them into
the task queue, which
is Google's distributed
queueing service.
And that task queue
will farm out the image
to a managed virtual
machine on our back end.
That back end has
OpenCV installed.
It'll solve the puzzle,
and then return it.
And will impress a lot
of people, I'm positive.
So if you've developed an
App Engine application,
the app.yaml on the left
will be somewhat familiar.
But it's not that complicated.
What we're going to do is-- this
is talking about our front end
here-- we've got
a Python runtime,
because we at
Google love Python.
We've got some
handlers for the URLs.
And we're going to
use some libraries.
It's not super-important.
On the right-hand side is
our back end specification.
And this is what we're running
on those virtual machines.
And the things to
note here are these.
This VM colon True
tells us that we're
going to be running on a
managed virtual machine.
And these VM settings
at the bottom
tell us what's going on there.
So we're going to run on
an n1-standard-1-- this
is one of our standard instance
types for Compute Engine--
and we're going to
install some software
with this apt.get
install section.
And we're obviously going
to be installing OpenCV,
but you could install whatever
you want there, right?
You can think of what
your use case would be.
And then to deploy
it, it's one line.
G Cloud app update,
and then the path
to your application directory.
In this case, we're in
our application directory.
So let's do the live demo.
And I think actually have
to unlock my machine now.
So one second before we switch.
OK.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
Awesome.
So this is our nifty--
where's my mouse?--
App Engine front end.
And what we're going to
do is capture a picture.
And so you know
that it's live, hi.
We're going to do some magic
and take a picture of our--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
can't see your face.
Let's see your face.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Aw, man.
I had already set it up.
Hi.
OK.
So let's capture
this Sudoku puzzle.
And the image recognition
software is looking for lines.
So it can do line detection.
And it's going to
look for these lines
on the outside to
recognize the puzzle.
You could probably
do this in a bit more
of a sophisticated way.
But it's a demo.
It illustrates the concept.
So let's focus it, shall we?
Yeah.
So much better.
Now nobody gets a migraine.
So let's take an image.
Looks pretty good.
Could be better.
But what we're going to do
now is tell it to solve it.
We're going to pray
in the demo gods.
Make a sacrifice.
Oh, no.
And this is how you
know it's a live demo.
So let's try it again.
We're going to use
a different puzzle.
Mandy can confirm this
worked during rehearsal.
She'll back me up here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Yeah, I think so.
Let's see.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Could we maybe
lower the lights on the stage?
Would that be possible?
Let's see if that works
a little bit better.
How's that look, guys?
Let's try it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Did
that actually change?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah.
OK.
Whoo!
Sanity check.
Yes!
Oh!
Woo-hoo!
We got it!
[APPLAUSE]
So this is your day to
learn how to impress.
Impress your colleagues.
Impress your friends.
And we'll go back to the
slides, if you get a chance.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Was it correct?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: You know what?
AUDIENCE: Check these out here.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: I'll
let you check that out.
We'll file a bug with
Peter Norvig if it isn't.
OK, so that's our live demo.
But what happens if this
application gets under load?
App Engine auto-scales.
Problem solved!
No.
No, right?
So App Engine does auto-scale.
So once traffic
increases, we will
increase the number of front
ends for you automatically.
Which is awesome.
But that task queue will just
get longer and longer, right?
Because we have a number
of virtual machines.
They'll keep going.
They'll keep returning puzzles.
But what we actually
need to do is
increase the number
of virtual machines--
the managed VMs--
on the back end.
And you can actually do
this programmatically,
simply with one line.
We use the modules library and
set the number of instances.
And because you
actually know what's
going on on the back end--
we actually don't, right?
We don't necessarily
know what your flow is.
Do they know we're using
OpenCV to solve this puzzle?
Probably not.
They know we have
OpenCV installed.
But you know what the
heuristic is going to be.
And so you can tell
us when to scale up
the number of instances--
and to scale down-- simply
by calling this line.
Cool.
OK.
So that's-- I think
we're at the end here.
But don't worry.
I return on stage
at some point today.
So the thing to take
away is this choice
that you've been told that you
have to make-- infrastructure
or platform-- it's
a false dichotomy.
It operates in between the two.
We have a great
set of technology
that helps you out doing that.
And letting you
break the glass when
you need to move up,
in terms of agility,
or down, in terms
of flexibility.
And we're only getting started.
So we hope you join us.
And we can't wait to
see what you build.
So thank you.